so can you tell us more about the
restaurant act uh
and um and walk us through the decision
making so
um we've been in the midst of this
pandemic now for
six months i agree with you obviously
it's not ending anytime soon
and you had to make a host of very
difficult decisions around different
uh teams different restaurants where it
sounds like you've
closed several for good but of the 70
many you hope to reopen you've reopened
many
under a limited capacity where it sounds
like you've brought back about 30
of workers uh and they're they're likely
doing a lot of
takeout and curbside um they're not
bringing people
in so
what does the decision to
keep a restaurant open look like how
flexible have you found landlords to be
in terms of let's say those 87 percent
of restaurants you obviously
don't have the revenue coming in to pay
rent uh
if you are a landlord i'm thinking well
okay my this restaurant can't pay me
but if i foreclose on this restaurant
then am i really gonna get a new tenant
in during this time
probably not um but it but it seems like
a lot of these
landlords themselves often owe money um
in various ways like they financed their
property
so even if they wanted to forgive the
tenant
they might have a hard time doing so and
i'd imagine you're even having those
kinds of conversations with some of your
landlords
me personally and i know it's been many
people trying to guide
small restaurant owners that maybe
we were not so good in understanding how
to renegotiate
with a landlord we need to understand
that many landlords
are suffering too we need to recognize
these number one
many landlords are maybe
they own the buildings where the
restaurant is but maybe
they have to be paying the bank also
the loans on the property they acquire
and
we are all together on this but it makes
a lot of sense to understand that if a
landlord
is is not willing to compromise at the
end of the day
that restaurant will end closing and
that landlord is not going to be
finding anybody to take over that that
the space anytime
soon so myself we've been able to
negotiate obviously i'm very lucky
because
i have a very good financial team around
me
that brings me wisdom but we've been
negotiating
our different leases and
overall we found good landlords willing
to compromise
and the compromise is all of the buff
from postponing some payments to even
uh taking away a few months off
the table um going maybe from
some fixed random structures to more
percentage fee structure so everybody
commits
uh it's many options that everybody
should be exploring
but i know it's been good people out
there trying to give
a small restaurant owners and maybe they
had the savvy
on adapting to these new situations
that can help everybody used to find
compromise i do believe
compromise wins the day and where
the states or the cities through the
mayors can
can do something to bring certain logic
i think will be in the best interest of
everybody i don't see america again
with every single corner every single
storefront shut down
if we want to have economic growth again
we need
to position the businesses and
especially restaurants
to be able to be part of that economic
pose covered 19th so
uh in the early days everybody is
familiar now with the ppp
which was an early idea that white house
congress put forward
the idea was okay but as we know
all of the time we realized that the
restaurants we were becoming
the unemployment uh facility instead of
taking care of the people through the
traditional unemployment
office uh all of the time the
restaurants were doing this but people
thought that oh this is great this is
coming to the restaurants
well it didn't the restaurants
i was very happy because we were able to
be paying employees me i was able to get
ppp
again it's good to have a good a good
team of advisors and lawyers and
that knows how to navigate those
waters but many small restaurant owners
didn't had
that power and many of those ppp
were not didn't go to
to a small restaurant owners
so i think a very small percentage
around eight ten twelve percent only
of what we call the independent
restaurant
um the irc uh coalition the independent
restaurant coalition
uh the vast majority of restaurants
didn't got any ppp
8 at all so the restaurant
act is an act that is being bipartisan
support
uh which is rare these days but the food
somehow brings everybody together to the
table
breaking bread still means something and
everybody understands the value that
restaurants bring across every community
in america every state
and ppp was more focused to provide
relief
to those restaurants half a million
restaurants
and more all across america the idea was
precisely to give
this grant that they could be uh
forgotten
uh uh that will be uh for the restaurant
owners to be able to pay
rent restaurant owners to
be able to do investment into the cost
associated with running restaurants
through this pandemic the amount of
money we have to be
investing on globes on masks
uh is used crazy use the the new setups
outside the
separation between tables this is extra
extra cost in a moment that the income
is not coming
so overall the restaurant act is just
trying to do this to put 120 billion
in the hands of more than 500 000
restaurants across
where restaurants can have the freedom
to use it
depends what they need it for so maybe
to
uh renovate the restaurant under the new
the new pandemic uh others obviously to
pay salaries
uh to pay rent to pay farmers to pay
bills
and i think will be has many other
things i recommend everybody used to
to google uh restaurant act and you'll
see more the details but overall is used
to bring relief
to the more than 500 000 restaurants
across america
also i've been pushing forward i i was
one of the founding members of of the
irc the
the independent restaurant coalition but
uh i
i very early on i focused myself on
feeding america
and i realized that this was an
emergency
a different type of emergency this is
not hurricane this is not an earthquake
and the restaurants were not affected uh
uh was not destruction but we were shut
down
so we had many americans that were
hungry that were about to be hungry
or hospitals that need somebody to be to
be
feeding them who better than restaurants
to do this so world central kitchen
we had almost 3 000 restaurants across
this pandemic
almost 40 million meals where the money
we were
receiving from people supporting our
feeding efforts
what we did was different this time we
began partnering with restaurants
across america more than 40 states and
pay the restaurant so the restaurants
could be open
the restaurants could be employing
people the restaurants could be paying
rent
the restaurants could be buy from the
local farmers
all of the sudden one dollar multiplied
by four
because it was covering many other
problems at once
that's why we push for the feed act the
feed act
is simple why we don't recognize that we
have an emergency
that is beyond the economic and the
health
emergency it's a humanitarian food
emergency
and by investing in restaurants through
fema
once the emergencies declare supporting
mayors and supporting governors and
where those people especially the mayors
that they are at the front lines
they can be activating those restaurants
to feed
the shelters to feed the hospitals that
they had to shut down their
the the the food operations uh the
homeless
elderly homes first responders it's a
smart idea where every dollar coming
from the federal government
will be multiplied by for tickling down
the economy and helping everybody you
feed the people in need in the process
you reactivate the economy
that passed congress and there's the
heroes act
uh pelosi was a big supporter but more
important we had bipartisan support
we had davis in illinois we had thompson
uh we had mcgovern we had uh hurt
who who sees bipartisan support and in
the senate we had team scott
south carolina kamala harris california
we had many more
all of a sudden a good idea that needs
the support
past congress is sitting on the senate
but unfortunately
uh the people in charge of the senate
right now is not very interested these
days
in bringing relief to american people
so the feed act is part of the heroes
act is that right
it passed early on uh but as you know
he's been sitting now for weeks in a
month in the senate
it's a great idea you know i when i saw
restaurants
yeah when i saw restaurants uh shift
to feeding hospitals and shelters and
the rest of it uh
and it employed people um i'm sure the
people were eating the meals were
incredibly grateful
and appreciative and the suppliers to
the restaurants so it is a win all
around and it goes to show
what you said earlier which is that
restaurants are so vital
and it should be bipartisan because
everyone loves restaurants who doesn't
love a restaurant
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you